Okay.
Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Getting Over It with Bennett Foddy.
I'm currently home...
Which means one thing...
That my save game file didn't come with me and I have to start Getting Over It all the way
back from the very very beginning.  So I'm gonna start this game doing something that I should have done a long time ago
Which is at the very heart of the matter, I should have just thrown myself in the ocean and drowned
but now that I've done that I can carry on. Now, the thing about this game is I'm
I'm a bit good at it. By now. I should be, right? if I wasn't good
if I wasn't good at it now, then I'm not doing something right. Right? So I better be good at it, or else I
*laugh*
Ah,
Shooty-tooties, see I've got a new mouse as well
Ya-EEE
C'mon
Oh shut up.
Shut up. Ooooh shut up
Shut up  NOOOOOOOOO-
Can you shut up do I have to listen to your drivel this whole goddamn time Mr. Bennet Foddy? Okay.
Yeah, shut up. Okay, so he's gonna draw.
No, no no, no NOOOOOO-
I know. I know. I played it
yyaAAAEEee.
Shut uuuup! (x1)
Shut uup! (x2)
Shut up. (x3)
Shut up. I just wana get back to where wAAAs
Ughhhhhgh
EEEWWGH-
Shut uup.
Shut up, I don't care
Oh, I don't care about your philosophical drudgery. Oh
*Bennet Foddy talking*
Shut up!
How do I shut you up? (*Voiceover volume Mark, below music*)
Just shut up
Good God!
Shut up. Who's calling me? Fuck off!
Why, why now when I just freakin' s- oh my god, this is a new Mouse - so it's oh
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH-
There's a muscle twitching in my forehead right here. I've never ever ever felt that muscle before in my life
Why am i stuck? 1x
Why am i stuck? 2x
Why am i stuck? 3x
Why am i stuck? 4x
AAAAAAAAAH Hhahah
OoOOoOh NO- AAAAAAAAAAAAAAA-
IT'S A  UUUGR
You guys don't understand what's going on right now with my mouse
This is a mouse that is number one. It's broken. It's been broken for years
I used to raid with this mouse in World at War AAAH I WAS RIGHT THERE!! I WAS RIGHT-
I was right there. 1x
I was right there. 2x
JUST GIVE IT TO MEEEEEE
I used to raid with this mouse and it's broken and I
blia-AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
COME ON!!!
I don't have another mouse
That's the thing I don't have another mouse cuz ALL of my mice that I have right now that I brought with me are
freaking oh
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO-
My god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god
Oh, god. Just got a I why am I even talking right now?
I shouldn't have even started the episode cuz I'm not anywhere where I ONCE WAS
OH MY GOD. I am feeling every ounce of it all over all over again. Why why I?
WHHHERE AM I GOING?!
You stay, you stay
GOOOOD. This mouse's range
It's just it's corded and the cord is like snagging on something and ♪ I don't~
LIKE IT ♪. okay.
Oh God, stop dribbling, stop dribbling. Okay. See the cord is fucking
See that shit? It's fucking- Did I just unplug it? No, no, nOOO YOU must DIE!
Fuck
No
Eeeeeeeeh
Eeeeeeeeeh
Wait why is my mouse visible now?
Wait what?
What? Wha- Why can I see my mouse now? What? What? What the hecking hell?
Wait
Wait. No! No! No?!
What?
What did- Why did that happen?
See this is what I mean. The mouse is broken it will disc-
Why is....
What?
Wait. Was  the obvious answer is just no?
No! It gonna start over again. I'm not gonna play with that because that's gonna mess me up
I don't know why. Don't ask me why it's gonna mess me up, but it's just gonna mess me up
And i don't want that.
*i n h a l e*
brbrbrrr.
No! Come- nooOoOoOoOoOoOoO!
What the hecking helll
You don't do that to me. I do that to my enemies
Not- Not you do that!
I why did I go so that way? See I'm pretty good at the game. Okay? I'm pretty
I'm pretty good at the game, noOoOoOoOooooh
Pretty good at the game
EeEeeeeeeeeee
Chihihihiii.
Hoh
Hup~
No! Why am I here now?
No! W-Why did you kno- OOOOOOOOOOH
OH MY GOOOOOOOOOOOOD
There we go 1x
There we go 2x
That's more stuff it - that's more like the stuff of it. No! That's not the it of stuff
HUEEEEEEE
HIYAA-
NOOOOOOOOOOOO- yes, Oh maybe so
*markiplier sounds* Mmkay.
God is that asshole still blabbering on and on and on! About his inane bullshit
Philosophical Philly Officer Farkle
oooh-yeEeEeEEe
Shoop!
There we go, okay
*Mark laughing*
I don't know if I can get through this part. ♪ It's one that drives me crazy! Crazy!
Crazy! ♪ Oh my god. Oh my oh my god
NOOOOOO! oh NOOO
WHY DID YOU DO- NOOOOOOOOOO
NOOOOOOO O O O O O O O O
Why did you do that?
You sack of shit 1x
You sack of shit 2x
You sack of shit 3x
You sack of shit 4x
You sack of shit 5x
You sack of shit 6x
I'm not even back to-
I just wanted to get up to that one point and then I would have been like:"
Hey! This is a good- this pretty much where I was were. That's what I wanted to-" NOOO. N-NOOOO.
No, that's what I wanted to know and then then I would have been fine
What were you doing there? What have you decided to do there?
Why did you just slam your whammy your bammy whammy on that thing? Don't you Frick fruck with me.
Climby!
No. Why? Nothing. Why nothing? Why would you
Don't you want to explain that to me?
No? Why are you doing? You're getting really Dancy-Lancie with this toilet here, and I don't much appreciate that
Haaaa!
Ok! Ther-
NnNnNnNNNNNNN
*Heavy breathing*
I love this game.
♪ Be a good little boy and behave ♪
♪ Be a good little boy in a black cauldron. Be a good little boy and behave ♪
(*Applause darnit*)
Yo, okay, all right. See? (*x4*) I'm almost back to where I was which is good
Which is very good. Very good.
Oooh yeaa.
Oooh yea
Ye- Yeeeeeeeea!
Yea that's the stuff
Oooh yeah,
oooh yeah, oh, yeah, oh yeah
Don't do the pull thingy. Oh, don't do the push thingy. Okay. Don't do the push. Don't do the pull don't do
Aaaanything at all
Okay
We're back to the midpoint of the livestream that I had before
Okay, I'm gonna turn the v/o back on because that least this stuff. I haven't heard ten bajillion times
No
The hoes the hoes
Uh oh x4
eh. eh
Rest ye merry gentlemen
Okay there you go, there's that and that's fun. Okay.
Oh shut up 1x
Shut up 2x
Ughhhh.
"Mark laughing"
Yeah, I could have refused yeah, I could've refuse
Are you really that knee-deep in your own sack of shit? You think that I could have... You couldn't  gonna refuse this. No.
I could not have refused this if I even wanted to. THEY wouldn't have let me.THEY- YOU
Wouldn't have let me!
Designer and Audi
Oh - Ah
Shit
Noooooooo...!!
No! Come on, babe
Wait a minute theEeEre-
Bronco, okay, you Broncos Tonko you just behave yourself
Guh~ no...
No right on the tip top of your nose you will no apparently the answer is not
*smashing table* Fuh FAAAAAAAACK
Dear not it is literally a level playing field. You could just not slip slide like a dick. You did swimming pool
No, what if that's new, okay? We'll just slip right off. Then. We'll just slip right though. No... NO!!
NOO! Come on!
*mark laughing maniacally*
Yeaaaaah.
There we go there we go, no don't slippy slap off the hat!
COME ON!
What is it the sloppy toppy from West of Loathing?
Fucking hell you were right there you dick waggler.
Really? REALLY? REA- AHAHA
That's the kind of bullshit that makes me fall all the way back to the bottom
And it makes me hate you that's the kind of shit that does that so don't do that! no. no. no. no
No, noooohohoho
No, literally do nothing that you're doing! This is the easy part. This is the easy part!
NooOOOO.
God damn it. No! God damnIt. Stop! This is the easy PAAAAART!
COME ON! GOD... Damn it!
Ugh... Just go- WAHAHAHAAAAAAY?!!
Ugh...
No, no, no, no, nooohohohohnoo....
Oh GooooooooOOODDDD!!
Oh, WHY?! Just climb it!! Just climb it...
Why am I getting caught up in the easy SHIT?!
Come on!! That was the oneeeee...
OH, STOP BOUNCING UP YOU... COCK WAGGLER!!
Why is this suddenly impossible?
Why in THE fucking world is this suddenly impossible for me?
God... There's just no way huh, there's just no way huh? it just don't happen anymore huh?
Oh it  just don't happen anymore. No no no it don't happen anymore no
I don't have the key anymore no no no no I don't have the golden ticket no more
No, no, no Charlie's Chocolate Factory is closed off to me.
Oh, oh oh, OH!
That did not do it no! No, that one, that one is a negative on that one. That's a big old no
Really, oh, that's a no boe
Yeah, sure. I'll slide all the way back to- NO! I'm not gonna get on that fucker's nose!
(*This part is fun to just listen to without context*)
Good god good- NO!!!!!
*Banging on the table* (Great drumming skills, Markimoo! :3)
No, oh my god, I just spilled a GODDAMN DRINK! I don't understand
What's happening right now at this one
juncture I am
right here
It's- Nothing's changed. I made it this far with relative ease
and
suddenly
Suddenly, I don't know why but things have suddenly
Decided to be the BIIIGGEST dick. Oh my god. Oh my god
I'm taking my time with this shit. I am taking
My fucking-
YES! YESS!!!!
YESSS!!!
Don't even know if the recording still work
Maybe my computer's gonna crash, maybe the microphone is broken
But I'm done with this one for now so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down in the comments below, and I'll get to the top of this mountain soon, so
Thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye bye!